we have got a bit of a signal from your
YouTube you are feeling us there's a
really good reason that video exists let
me explain welcome to a weird corner of
the internet called ASMR it's a tingling
sensation that people feel when
listening to specific sounds I'm drew
Coolidge I'm gonna explain what ASMR is
and how you can feel it too
this is hashtag news for this video you
may want to wear headphones because I'm
gonna show you some examples and it
could either feel really good or worst
case I helped you put on your headphones
so what is ASMR well here's a super
sciency sounding answer ASMR is
autonomous sensory meridian response
it's a pleasurable tingling sensation in
the head scout or bat in response to
visual auditory or tactile stimuli in
Normie terms its feel-good head tingles
from listening and looking at stuff more
than that ASMR is a subculture a small
but passionate section of the Internet
is dedicated to listening to and
creating audio and video experiences for
each other there are over 100,000
subscribers to the very active ASMR
section of Reddit mainstream news has
covered it how is this not sexual
it is not there's numerous YouTube
channels filled with strange videos of
accented foreigners talking to the
camera it is the best time to put the
lotion on scare people role-playing and
doctors teachers robots there are videos
that are just loops of people rubbing
clothes or other mundane tasks like
blow-drying a towel for two hours
why else with this video of a chore have
6 million views other channels
specialize in creating ASMR content and
others go even further and take
role-playing requests like this popular
series where you are a space Voyager in
a pod traveling to another planet or
this video where you are kidnapped
Batman and Harley Quinn taunts you this
is actually kind of cool this may all
sound incredibly weird like super weird
but for those that can experience ASMR
it's not unfortunately not everyone can
but are you one of the people maybe
let's find out put on your headphones
find your triggers everyone has
different triggers so you need to find
out what works for you but normally just
everyday sounds
there's also a whole set of triggers
that includes youtubers acting out
real-world scenarios that you may have
experienced in your own life like
doctor's office I'm just going to do a
quick assessment I'm going to take your
temperature haircuts ear cleaning I'm
sure you're familiar with the is rate
and massages that's it really if he felt
something with those experiences then
you probably had it varrock c13 the
people who have ASMR feel random head
tingles throughout their whole life
without realizing what was triggering it
if you're not one of those people then
I'm sorry that's just the weird way the
world works I'll buy you an ice cream
next time I see you how about that
Ted make sure I never see that guy okay
thanks I can some people here and others
not
I don't know and neither do scientists
in fact that's part of the problem
there's no official research that's been
conducted about ASMR or what the
official physiological response really
is although one study has shown that it
can help improve your mood and sometimes
alleviate pain it's like SNM where for a
subset of the population pain can feel
pleasurable but instead of whips and
leather you have headphones and
whispering and now for the most
important burning question everyone has
no no it's not yes titles it's not
sexual it's just a relaxing thing but it
can be kind of private it's like
meditating which isn't sexual last time
I checked if it was then this guy would
be quite the pimp please someone tell me
what is sexual about taking your
computer in your room shutting the door
and watching this video oh yeah yeah I
can see how that okay but it's not
sexual okay trust me
it's just a pleasant sense
station triggered by some pretty
out-there videos I'll be honest I
personally have ASMR I found out about
it very recently I was looking to buy a
suit and I was searching for a video
about suit fitting I came upon this one
so during this video I kept getting
these pulsating head tingles from the
sound of the fabric or the hosts low
voice most customers do not know this
size but I had no idea why I looked in
the comments and a bunch of people were
talking about something called ASMR and
then I just follow that down the rabbit
hole and you can too a cool facet of
ASMR is the active online community this
is a special group of people that found
each other the internet brought these
people together this isn't a
scientifically group together series of
individuals this is the Internet at its
best people with a small niche interest
coming together and celebrating it as a
community if you enjoyed this
explanation please subscribe to NMR not
a SNM are just nm are that's confusing
can't change the name of the channel
comment with your experiences with ASMR
when did you first feel it tell us about
your favorite videos what's the weirdest
video that you've seen tell me down in
the comments thanks for watching and
listening
I'm drew Coolidge if you're I can't hear
you I'm doing the ASMR did you know
watch the whole video sorry we can do
back
most effective brands